hello happy Wednesday everybody I'm Eric
that's Aaron Eddie we are checking out
bigger beta which I guess you can get as
long as you're an Xbox insider
would you just go into the store to
download yeah so if you're we can
discuss how to get into that in a second
we're trying to get into a game right
now it's matchmaking to fisk factory
aaron's played a few matches so he's
gonna be kind of our guide here today
but why don't we show you that loading
screen all it says piss factory here
I'll prove it to you just kidding
someone Croft might my son Croft my full
game damn it to Marian Mike you guys are
killing me you've been crop son he will
be messing with the the setup anyways it
was piss factory couldn't prove it to
you because the game thing my setup here
you got it mixed up a little bit but if
you guys are trying to get into it to
get the insider's app I guess is all you
have to do in on your Xbox is navigate
to the store and go to search you search
for Xbox insider hub and then you select
get an install and once you do that you
can then get bigger so yeah you can try
this out play it out it's from the same
devs
that brought us ARMA and Daisy
so Bohemia right Interactive yeah sort
of the in the vein of wandering around
collecting stuff and then deciding to
extract or fight your way on an airdrop
it's kind of like hunt showdown or
escape from tarkov in that way I mean it
I gotta be honest like right now it's a
very rudimentary game yeah it's a new
map - as someone mentioned because you
were playing on the snowy map the other
day right yes like yesterday I think so
yeah it's a new map Luke
so apparently just so you guys know it's
1991 the nuclear war is over Central
Europe is devastated Norway Norway has
become the Last Stand started as a
nameless Outlander well who will you
become no time for uncertainty though
turn a shelter into your home which
we'll check out later fight run or hide
I mean I mean the answer is you're gonna
come Norwegian I think
Pablo it's not so much of Battle Royale
it's more of like a survival game slash
like Peavy survival PvP in a way but
you're trying to extract I guess items
things like that to to take back to your
main base and then build up your main
base for what purpose we're not entirely
sure yet it seems like as you build up
your base you get a resources that are
produced in your base and I'm assuming
you use that to make weapons because
every time you die or ammo box you lose
it all no no shoot him nope yeah and I
got stabbed in that guy's joke
so apparently stabbing is the way to go
yeah you know what Rob and I were
playing yesterday we had a couple times
where we shot at somebody running at us
I swear just the bullets all vanished
and the guy stabbed us to death so not
not too sure about hey registration in
this game yet again this is a early
access so work-in-progress yeah I'm
gonna show you guys the base now because
I got stabbed
can you play in a squad I don't think so
I think it's just solo not for
PlayStation or PC yet no crime I'm not
afraid to play for night that's not till
tomorrow so is that your okay so this is
your base this is where your dude or
lady hangs out mm-hmm got a nice view
there's a shooting range in the back but
now that I've died I have nothing so you
lost your gun and everything everything
yeah so like these games I would just my
personal opinion but I would call them
gear bleed games I feel like they're
mostly designed like supposedly they're
designed for tension I feel like they're
mostly designed just to drain your gear
for whatever purpose I don't know like
you know when you get any gunfights
you're just that huge risk of losing
everything and then you could get to a
point in these types
games where you just don't have enough
stuff to compete and then you're just
running around like knife ink knife guy
there so here's the base building you
can see you can add things to your
crafting table scrap bin maybe a little
bit of electricity you can customize
your character here's your resource
screen you can customize your character
and I'm just kid show you guys the
shooting range it looked like there's
some dance emotes and stuff in there
Beck Hansen just so you know if you have
the Xbox insider program you basically
can play the beta for free right now
so yeah so here's a shooting range you
can come here practice with your weapons
the game does have aimed down sights and
it does have a pretty decent menu in the
back for customizing sensitivity both
aiming down sights and just walking
around gotcha someone earlier Mitch I
think was Ethan says like it plays like
tarkoff it does yeah and I'm curious for
people who because I know there are
people out there who like these types of
games I think what they like is those
the risk/reward aspects of it mm-hmm
I feel like it kind of D incentivizes
gunfights because if you get new again
fight and you lose all your stuff then
you're just kind of hos I know tarkoff
has a PvE mode to help out with that
okay so let me let me focus here real
quick on you into a game yep cool make
sure I actually have a weapon what's up
zero King hopefully I didn't just queue
in without any bullets send us any Leo's
this is bigger bigger beta specifically
and as mentioned I had asked this
earlier but you weren't able to
multiplayer right it's just basically
you there's eight eight people in a
match and it says gotcha so I want to
make sure I think then the website they
said 8 to 16 I've only seen 8 players
currently how's it going out there so
yeah like if anybody plays escape from
tarkov or hunt showdown I'd love to hear
what it is about those games that that
appeals to you like that again it could
just be the the big risk reward
maybe it's that you don't necessarily
want to get into gunfights all the time
because it is such a risk and it seems
like the incentive in this game is to go
scavenge a couple houses and then just
bail with mm-hmm your stuff so you can
keep it and go into the next round
makes sense I mean I don't know as you
had mentioned earlier and we've only
played a little bit or you and Rob have
played a bit but it's interesting for
you to be like well why do I kill
someone else right because you don't
know how much stuff they have in your
case when you died there he got your gun
and some other stuff so that it was kind
of worth it cuz he probably wasn't
risking a lot with just his knife
potentially but um there's a question
here from game changer dan how big are
the maps big not so far so far they're
actually pretty small this is the whole
map here this is like the size of my
character icon so I don't know maybe go
around the corner here and we'll explore
this so this is like a are those exits
these are active okay you can leave it
any time kind of like hunt chair down so
honestly you just kind of want to
scavenge oh I took a lot of bulls with
me okay let's go single-fire currently
it's just on xbox for those asking
platform wise even on the bohemian
interactive or the vigor game website it
only shows xbox one but who knows if
down the road there will be PC or
something like that but yeah so I'm
gonna go take a hike and you know
normally I think you might not want to
engage other players until you build up
a decent arsenal but if you have a gun
because you can end up in you can end up
like knife emic knife guy there who
actually you know to be fair did pretty
well he killed you
yeah you did kill me with this knife so
maybe maybe knifey style is the way to
go in this game Luke says you really
want to go after the airdrops
that makes the gunfights worthwhile okay
so there must be some goods have you
open an airdrop yet not yet this so the
air drops appear to be in a radiation
zone and if you don't take your meds
then you get irradiated OOP and
hopefully I don't get stuck in the
geometry what's up Sagan Sagan perhaps
you on sooo this is a bigger game
changer dan says it's a strange game for
the ARMA team to develop if the gunplay
doesn't look as good as ARMA either
I've also noticed some things such as
when you're aiming it doesn't exactly
Center like it goes like Oh like I saw
it lately to the left of where you
Center your crosshairs which I I know
battlegrounds have that problem when it
when you go first-person do you know I
you can only go first person like that
iron sights gotcha and there what did
you feel any aim assist it didn't seem
like it
no but the not that I noticed but the
main menu definitely or the options menu
has a lot of options that was redundant
statement the options menu has a lot of
advanced options for you to customize
acceleration customize how sensitive it
is when you aim down sights there's a
lot of toggles you can throw to get it
how you like it I will say in this early
access build it erased every time I
turned off the Xbox it actually erased
so your settings weren't saving ya erase
my settings so and you can do things I
like in games like shoulder swap and you
can open windows which I thought was
kind of cool so like alright if I need
to bail out a window you can do that to
get some items here yeah they're good
all right I got a gas cans we needed
that I needed it to gas things are there
vehicles none that I have seen so far
and we are so we're here we're just kind
of looting I guess we can work our way I
mean well the air drops gonna take place
somewhere in here so we might as well
circle in that direction okay
garage is a survival shooter where
you're like trying to essentially you
know gather up materials get those
materials out so that you can further
your base and or like have materials for
like the next fight etc hopefully maybe
we can get an airdrop or see what that
looks like and see you know how
worthwhile that is cuz that's probably
the you know one of the bigger things
you're going after which is why other
players are going after it which is why
you would then you know get into
encounters and flights and things like
that
but yeah it's not a br game because
there's only 8 to 16 people and it's not
necessarily like whoever wins the round
wins the whole thing it's more it's more
like you don't want to die because if
you die you lose your stuff
right lose your stuff it's a you lose
your stuff kind of game where you go
scavenge so for a game audio i can doors
open so nope
yep that doors open so maybe somebody
went through here how many players per
match I think 8 to 16 so far yeah we've
seen a so far does it tell you that in
the game like or howhow did you know
that there was 8 I guess he just said
that somebody were matching in oh this
house is probably scavenged you get full
auto just in case this guy still here
this is more like tarkoff as someone
mentioned than it is like Pope jeez so
everyone's guy really yes alright I
missed them no fall damage no fall day
yeah although you got the ankle snags
from that opening it's a medicine
because I don't have any all right well
we'll find a guide just for fun and
we'll see what happens
I did not see him but I was looking at a
202 people are [ __ ] down better side
bus de marrón this is the best time is
when you flank up areas there's one he's
aiming at someone else right yeah
good God get that flag get that flake he
went it that it so it doesn't show if he
killed that guy huh he ran around the
corner I didn't get him no no no I'm
saying if he killed the other guy
because he was clearly fighting someone
else oh yeah I think he got him he's
looting his body we got a we got to get
that leaped show them those sick dolphin
dive Oh call of duty just kidding
oh I hear airplane that's good we're
also gonna attract other players he's
there where are ya he's probably
bandaging up where'd you go
where is he right there god oh yeah go
down got him
hopefully that was the same guy it was
it was I'm pretty sure based off what he
was wearing
so the airdrop definitely happened we're
gonna loot this guy hopefully hopefully
it's safe it's a on the other side of
the truck single fire I've noticed is
pretty important in this game back to
you if you go full on it oh look at all
these goodies
thank you give us your give your bullets
oh he's at it he has a bandage and oh
you got a lot you meant to his face
all right I noticed the flip side of
that is when you get back to your base
you tend to not have a lot of places to
stuff it okay so is there bleeding or
anything or just normal health systems
Barney seems pretty normal
the only thing that where you lose
health a bit is during the radiation
areas like you'll start to tick decay so
yeah in the bottom right there you can
see I did have health loss it was just
in like temporary
oh you got shot though so yeah yeah yeah
okay so go back to my first gun I mean
let you see the airdrop or does it show
on the map it does honestly this the
smart thing for me to do right now would
be to just get out no it's way over here
this is I think the air drops actually
in the radiation region how do you know
that's what the giant red is probably
telling me so if another player grabs it
though you can actually see it like it
it's like the hunter down it actually
like flickers on the map you know he
killed that another guy over here - he
probably looted his body though I would
assume because he had a lot of stuff
probably wouldn't bring that much stuff
with you right good recommendation in
the chat to reload both of my weapons so
that I can just switch between the two
of them yeah get to the same good
is the Mosin good Noah it is I'll tell
Aaron to go back and grab that he said
the other gun when I'm better I am but I
don't know I'm gone awful with the
single action single fire weapon stories
support what we're doing our fortnight
strats a double SMG it's important to
know where you stand in life and where I
stand in life is I am terribly pelipper
both action weapons all right so we're
gonna go to radiation area just to show
you what that looks like maybe the drops
over there too if we weren't knee-deep
in action I probably told Aaron to kind
of look up to see where the drop was but
so oddly enough actually you hear the
airplane sound but I did not see him
buddy never see like something drop out
of the sky I didn't see a model for the
actual airplane frag and hamish so far I
believe it's just xbox one so but if you
have the insider's program which is not
hard to get you can play for free the
beta so I would check that out if you're
interested or keep watching making make
a decision for yourself it's a sniper
guide John Smith yeah he said that he
errands
I don't appear to her to not use is this
an iPad oh I guess that makes sense that
he took me more busy he shoulda took the
sniper instead of the pistol I get it to
extract or just yeah I mean because the
the sniper is probably a better better
get than the pistol but whatever it
doesn't really matter where we came up
either way I'm just being honest there's
ami mode I don't believe so
okay so now we're getting into the
radiation zone although I don't have any
how do you counteract it you need to
have the meds I think you have the meds
and that maybe that's why again like we
will only got this yesterday so maybe
that's what we're base building
oh my table or do you have the meds to
kind of fight your way through it
yeah so you can craft the meds I mean if
I get too radiated I guess I can just
escape just remember that you decay
while after the fact - right like I
remember watching you going to the zone
and then like eventually you kind of got
sicker and he just died I think yeah I
mean you can get out of the zone so I'm
in the zone right now doesn't look like
anybody's picked up the airdrop or found
the edge
but is there is that marker your marker
or the airdrop marker that's me the Reds
me and that's where I put my own so I
can just get rid of it yeah I'm just
wondering it for sure that the air drops
in this zone don't know if it's coming
to a PC Jasper doesn't say so on the
site right now they're the official site
beta only right now are there better
sites than the iron site so was a
question haven't seen them yet but
somebody recommended that we picked up a
sniper rifle a little bit earlier which
we didn't do oh there it is
oh nice okay look like everything else
in the world so I need to chart a way
out I mean and I grabbed this other
players will come after me does this
mean somebody else picked it up you said
that's how it works just don't get out
early or would it tell you that they got
out what up Chet will throw this you can
actually the first time I've gone to
when his ear drops I think the air drops
gone says Luke okay like get on at the
game like someone got it and pieced out
cuz that wouldn't be shocking so should
we be looking for a new game then at
this point so that's the peace out point
we'll just go peace out then yeah that's
fine we gotta kill we got we got another
gun we can store that gun we got a lot
of Ambo nishan somebody might have
grabbed it like being close to get out
yeah like that I would have just grabbed
it and ran I wouldn't even engage in a
fight like see yeah we'll try that the
next round yeah we gotta look up uh do
you know if it always drops in the red
zone so far I believe it does okay
doesn't seem like the radiation is doing
anything yeah I don't know that was
weird it does there's a certain point
where it starts making your vision go
blurry yeah I saw that yesterday yeah we
fled cool
so fleeing is I feel like a very good
strategy in this game it's one of those
things where maybe you want to come in a
couple rounds and build up your reserve
of weapons and ammo and then meds and
then maybe go for the airdrop when
you're ready I mean to be fair there's
gonna be a good amount of loading how
long this is a circle get is it was it
at max capacity or there it's okay so
that was the biggest was gonna get yeah
so the marker shows up red when it drops
turns yellow when it has been picked up
hmm all right so we're so like if we put
a marker in the red circle then it
becomes yellow if it's been picked up so
we're gonna drop off one of our rifles
Antonio Adrian I believe if as long as
you get the Xbox insiders program you
can pretty much play this game for free
and I think the Xbox insider preview
program thing is also free I had
mentioned how to do it earlier you can
just google it if you want
so says I'm not always sure if it drops
in the red
ok well we'll just try to listen and see
the plane it spills 310 is this a
survival game yeah pretty much I mean
you're going into a match you're trying
to loot as much stuff out of you know
and resources that you can because
you're trying to bring it back to your
base which is where we're at where you
can craft different things we haven't
crafted too much stuff outside of like
our gun maybe at some point you can
craft like medicine and bandages and
things like that but so yeah I have a
painkiller the crafting table so
crafting table tools level zero so I
need wire and metal parts so I think you
have to build all this that's that's the
deal okay so
Kalinka asks what is this game most like
some people were saying it's like
tarkoff and maybe you like a little bit
do you escape with Mattson tarkoff was
that more of a hunch showdown thing hunt
you down that's kind of like a hybrid of
a bunch of stuff it's more survival than
battle royale dos so anyone that's asked
saying like battle royale blah blah blah
it's not talk I've had some mysteries as
you go across the map and there's an
extraction point at the end of the map
typically your chances of surviving a
round of tarkoff I think are almost none
unless you're rolling with a really good
crew so you're just gonna kind of gear
bleed the whole time oak says you can
have a friend invite you to the Xbox
insiders if they're already a member
that's cool thanks for that I don't have
that many bullets in this a cave but I
don't know why don't we try it just
for the hell of it so this school they
have a shooting range here you can test
out the accuracy of your weapons
practice dolphin diving shark fair child
says this game is really good because
it's coming going to be on ps4 not as of
now they'd the ps4 crabs really looking
for something that isn't for night I
know that they were pretty enthused
about h1z1 yeah
they are king of the kala mode well
that's now h1z1 less racing I don't
understand your question so you're gonna
have to reformulate that one for me to
try to hopefully answer or read yeah the
guns definitely pulling left when I go
down sights oh that time Oh like if I
was going for a headshot they would miss
so you got a 80s and then pull right
just a teeny bit yeah you don't have to
engage literally take scraps from like
locations and then bring it back yeah oh
how long does a game last uh I mean I
think it lasts as long as you want it to
be until you die or get out right out of
ceiling if you go for I think it's like
10 or 15 minutes if you actually go for
the airdrop assuming you don't die wait
could you could you have stayed on that
map just now and like tried to scavenge
other parts of the map or would up kick
you out at some point if I had thought
that all the other players were gone I
probably could have stayed for a while
we can test it I mean we can ask
questions so it's kind of like not a big
deal I'd rather just see what it's like
again airdrop more of a rust Isle yeah
although it's instance I think rust is
on a like a fairly large map from
whatever call same with pop G like hub
G's maps are huge this is maybe one
corner of a pub G map it's like the
power plant area or something like Oh a
being Ben boy says what's so special
about this game I think it's just from
my perspective it's like giving players
on the Xbox another type of game that's
not necessarily just about a rail that
has you know
I wouldn't say similarities to it but
you know it has it has elements of
different things and maybe your survival
shooter is more of your thing also it
has like you know more realistic look
and things like that so that's my
venture to guess so yeah
given this as early access I would
recommend go try hunt the show down to
see if that's your kind of game or
escape from tarkov just play a couple
rounds and see if it's your kind of game
some people really really like the like
how punishing these games are and how
you really do have to you know worry
about every gunfight as opposed to a
Call of Duty style game where you know
you just respawn before you hit the
floor half the time Antonio this is not
a battle rail so for ya it's pretty much
a survival game you're trying to you
know loot materials and things from like
buildings like this to try to bring back
to your actual base I mean you might run
into other players of which this map has
8 out to your left that cabinet was
explorable usually and if you do happen
to run into people and you know kill
them you can essentially take their loot
which is you know what happened last
game we're able to take that guy's ammo
and guns which is pretty valuable in the
sense that if you know you'd have to
craft those things which is materials
obviously so yeah I haven't fully sorted
out crafting yet it seems like you need
to build the biggest hurdle right now
from for my characters electronics so I
need to get fine electronics and build a
crafting table from what I understand as
we mentioned yeah according to the
website right now it seems like it's
just an Xbox exclusive because that's
the only platform that was Hawk says how
can i play this you need to be an Xbox
insider and if you are then you can you
know once load up that app and then look
for this game should be able to play it
that way I'm gonna try it shooting out
not a battle royale Schwartzenegger
to survival shooter survival scavenging
slash building
I guess building crafting zero King as
mentioned from what era No
the the size of that circle is about
roughly as big as it's gonna get
that's where I got Stephanie people ask
uncharted this one has eight but you can
potentially have 8 to 16 people maps is
what the official site says itself ooh
tiny hop in the car the scavenge and the
reload button are on the same oh really
impress you that's not so great I'm
wondering if I'm not gonna run into
somebody here it's kind of how it goes
Mad Hatter people are preconditioned to
relive it constantly no to think that
when you're looting in a game like this
like that's a shooting game that's a
battle rail I mean that's where rad in
the industry right now I spent a lot of
time with four-night over the past
couple weeks and I get it now like I
actually was really enjoying it to be
fair though I was playing team battle
and not actual battle royale yeah but be
ours are you know the the 2018 thing
slash 2017 things that you know people
are gonna ride that way for a bit and
then just like MOBAs it'll probably kind
of come down to medicine right there in
front of you if there's a good person
so it's up to you if you want to grab
that mess and probably sneak up on this
guy it's what I'm gonna come over to you
right oh maybe not
you want that medicine DUI I don't know
we do don't want to get shot getting it
and I've looked over there he sees you
maybe I think you just saw me I think I
saw you yeah it's alright you see if I
can get an angle coming across the
bridge haven't tried firing through
windows yet is he gonna I feel like he
hid behind that Ridge to try to head
head Campea but I don't know question is
will he come to me or do I have to go to
hint I want to make him come to me that
would be more preferable so yeah we'll
see what happens I mean I my feelings
are that you know you have pub G and
fortnight and those are gonna be your
two heavy hitters at best there's maybe
room for one more battle royale game and
that's probably it so it's like do the
game devs take the risk to you know
Battle Royale game and hope that you
know it works out I'm curious about the
call Beauty one I want to see what that
looks like or how that works out yeah
that one sounds super interesting
because it's a kind of a play on
nostalgia to you're you know you're
gonna be like jumping that airplane and
telling your squad let's go to nuke town
or you know some other get to play some
way you're all the different characters
from the cod series yeah I don't know I
mean maybe maybe that's a thing or
becomes a thing there's so many people
that play cod now I don't know if the
that multiplayer well will kind of stick
or if the the community will be playing
that a bunch versus what they know
traditionally play but now and then
whatever battlefield decides to do I
know it's not like a traditional just
straight-up Battle Royale but you know
they're gonna they're gonna do something
all right
they just said Royale I think they never
showed anything though you're gonna
shout Cortis dia and jump out of an
airplane yep was that him there man do I
even want to fight him I don't know I'm
just waiting to see if the airdrop will
come where did this man go Luke
serious thinks that call of duty will
bookend the BR era maybe was he really
that close yeah I hear the footsteps
yeah
Oh God welcome to the aim in this game
his foot I think you should have used
the other gun the one you killed that
other guy with the like that
Oh their jobs coming in and again we're
engaged at the same location as last
game he's got the head he's got the head
glitch on you so I would either try to
flank him with the head glitch like he's
he's hiding behind the car because he's
not giving you much to shoot whereas
you're giving him a lot to shoot you
know what I mean he also doesn't know
where you are right now so if you
wrapped on him if you wrap around on him
right now make the bold play yeah he's
right he's behind that car behind the
car come on yes you just gotta get in
there yeah oh
all right so airdrops head around
somewhere to aaron so no you don't want
that yeah you want is a K you definitely
want it's a 74 OOP I pressed too quickly
for ya oh I don't know and I have to in
case oh wait no I actually for for the
pistol you go to the pistol probably and
then swap it and now I got to wait guess
I'll take it oh whatever
look for the drop the drop still there
it's a bread box on everything now I got
replace one of my a Ches oh that one is
40 though one is 20 okay we're doing
this so it's okay it's north of you or
west all right
40 rounds that a GE it kind of says we
on different servers good nice tree and
snap in here that aks no vehicles that
we know just FYI oh you're also really
hurt you don't have bandages right I
think I do and this is actually not
place to do that though
as he says that just Yolo Yolo he'll and
also I'm irradiated so let's figure out
our axis strategy so red means I am NOT
gonna type whenever it's yellow that
means somebody got it right
that's the a and now somebody has it ya
know somebody has it so where do you
think they're exiting that's what you
got to figure out top is the nearest oh
is he gonna get out before you can get
there very likely
the top area is easy to get to keep
fighting people instead of getting these
sick air drops I think he's out
Oh is he like right next to you no no
heshes just go for the exit right the
eggs that you think he's gonna go to
well he just went the other way so I
thought he was gonna go there but then
he started hitting okay well then Foley
was that a blink here I thought it was
gonna go this way but I got a confusing
blink in the opposite may be here bait
nope he's he's going the other way oh
he's going a long way huh yeah it's very
hunch show down that way where people
have to mind you know cars that we know
right now no I do have bandages all
those can run heal I doubt it oh that
was cheeky oh no you just had
painkillers which is just like one kid
I'm not in pain anymore
surprise okay yes good this is good you
you guys have a little squabble we'll
come from behind where's it going down
fine near the exit figure out where the
exit was already it's over you know what
get in the water he's probably at that
boat I hope I heard something on the
water stereo guy in the water oh no
that's just the water and it was just
the water
crap easy out don't know okay so now I'm
getting irradiated probably means I'm
close to the guy that has it really all
right you know you're just losing life
and you should probably get the hell out
all right this is where I just had my
gunfight if I just stayed there would
have been good okay all right get me out
of here
not even a me and then right now I gotta
go back the other way yeah I think was
over here wasn't it okay
I don't know snoop I think Aaron's gonna
die but we'll see what's this about Noah
Noah it's a survival shooter you're
trying to I guess technically the big
thing you're trying to do is get the air
drop so that you can get materials from
that air drop so you can take them out
extract them to your base to then you
know kind of craft some stuff you can
also find items and materials and things
like that in these houses right now
we're irradiated because we've been in
the thing oh hi Oh Shivan she escaping I
think no he's trying to escape I think
oh I think he got out that's the exit oh
he's he's back there he's back there
he's in the bar turn around he's right
there
oh I thought he was right there oh yeah
I think he's out you saw some guy like
kind of peak is headed behind this box I
think he just escaped well played random
other guy he just ran around pop some
radix we didn't have any well we still
got we got some loot out of that that's
good all right so this time this round
we'll just focus on the airdrop okay
famished Yoshi is there anything you can
compare this to tart escape from tarkov
hunt show down somewhere and read
between those two don't shoot no I want
to we wish we should have killed that
guy so we could have took his loot cuz
we were out anyways
so it's airdrop games now I see well I
mean it's not just air jobs cuz you
could still escape from just crafting
stuff I mean for crafting materials from
the houses but I would assume the air
jobs have the good stuff so have you
been able to upgrade anything yet or is
that just not a thing you can upgrade
things because weren't you saying you're
missing stuff but I don't have the the
Ray it's not no co-op guys just
single-player from what we can tell 8 to
16 players per map alright I've got a
Wii it is not a battle royale game way
too much ammo don't necessarily want to
carry amo it doesn't even seem like you
use more than 30 rounds a match that's
true there is your spraying and praying
here's 7 6 to 9 by 19 another battle
rail see if any more 7 6 - nope the
Cooper man if you feel that way you
don't have to be here you know it's
simple as that
ok so thanks everyone else for hanging
out so you guys know this games about
live we're live every day at about 11:30
today we're a little bit later than our
normal schedule but you can come hang
out with us we'll play different games
betas previews games that have weekly
challenges things like that Aran's now
at the crafting station oh you had an
improve thing the improve I think you
actually had it yeah 4,000 materials you
can have a wood log which I don't know
what that does exactly so we need nails
and wire I haven't really found wire no
no that's the next upgrade did you
already do that upgrade you can't do
that upgrade oh ok so you need nails and
why need nails and wire so like I have
some of this stuff I'm assuming once you
get these online you can actually craft
some business here's my character
there's customization gestures is not in
the game yet it's store so
loadout there is a section in here for
breaking down and customizing weapons
but again I don't know this is a problem
I have with escape from tarkov is why
would I spend so much time customizing a
weapon and then if you just die that's
it it's gone right oh if that weapon is
really good then you should be winning
around this technically right and like
you said like we are not even sure how
good these air drops are right so let's
focus on an air drop this time around
how do I get this game gauge basically
you need to be an Xbox insider if you're
not you just need to get on to your Xbox
console search for Xbox insider app
install that and you should be able to
look for the game that way I believe so
yeah is there a release date not that I
know of all right I feel like that's
just to scare the crap out of you in
games like this because it's very quiet
and then suddenly I shotgun to go in the
back the other day was just laying on
the ground I'm sure I think it's just so
bigger will release 2018 for those
purchasing the founders pack and then
2019 as a free-to-play so there's that
for the individual who was telling me to
aim down sights earlier I've noticed
that the sights are off a little bit to
the left so I'm usually hesitant in a
closed situation to do it although these
guns are really inaccurate when you go
full auto so point taken
it's worth a shot also backseat gaming
is the way to go and that's how it goes
I appreciate when you backseat game take
is you usually know things oh okay well
I was gonna say sometimes the the chat
got it too but you know your advice on
the flank was good yeah good flunky
because like I feel like was given the
aiming I've seen I'm like why would we
even try to have a mid to long range by
it let's just bring it up and close with
the with our you know full auto SMG and
you know just hope that we hose them
down before they hose us down right
somehow yesterday that ended with both
Rob Handler and myself getting stabbed
to death at point-blank range
just that guy that guy pulled it off
yeah on you earlier but he got probably
half of your
Health gone from you looting a box early
crime says there's a he's in the game he
has no nut no ammo or no gun or anything
so don't shoot him he's gonna be our
bait I guess sure part of me doesn't
believe him but part of me goes well
we're focused on the airdrop anyways
ray Tolliver as mentioned get the Xbox
insider app on Xbox after you do that
then search for the four bigger and you
should be able to hopefully get in
that's all I can really say we haven't
we might have a good article on gamespot
eventually by the end of the day which
kind of hopefully will help point you in
the right direction I might be able to
link let me see if I can link you guys
how to get in think there's this right
here so let me send this out there and
then you guys can use this as like a
means to to get in I guess or hopefully
get in so let me figure out where the
airdrop is and what it's in the ocean
that's just you ready whoa it's gonna
blow in I don't know we'll find out I
mean maybe it doesn't matter right now
maybe the circle gets dropped with the
plane you know what I mean so the planes
gonna come from there and then come
across and drop it somewhere so why
don't you just look for other random
stuff until you hear the plane I guess
it's the big thing that I need is wire
and I'm not sure if I get that yet by
breaking down materials or funny I think
you found nails earlier and just like a
toolbox are there boss like tarkoff I
don't know no not yet
I don't know if they'll be in the game
but not currently
I definitely was also not shooting
through that car but that dude
as you shouldn't you know I have
armor-piercing rounds you know hollow
hollow points I wonder about the windows
so nothing in this store there's a thing
got some bullets your pull-up I guess
you got plenty of bullets not in the
same game sad face right now cuz I I
think it's just Xbox one
I don't believe PC because I didn't see
it
Dave the rave its it's just in beta
right now not like officially out yet
these are fish drying racks new fish how
balanced are the controls and might have
to elaborate on what you mean by that I
guess that's fair
so far serviceable um although we'll say
the reload and the pickup button on the
same button so you will oftentimes
reload when you're trying to pick up
hope and your gunshots it's always here
man it's always around here oh they're
going ham
I heard someone just unloading their gun
which I don't craft molotovs that I
don't know I'm sure at some point once
you get your crafting bench up or
something maybe you can make those I
don't even know if I saw them if they're
unloading
they're probably missing that's kind of
its it's got that arm of vibe Jameer
this is not a better oil game that's the
extraction are there any explosives
I saw a grenade in the menu but I
haven't used it where are the players
there's only seven other players in here
of which maybe one of them just died
because we heard oh there you see you
see that what the hell is that oh it's
nothing it's just this flower that's
flickering that was throwing me off was
like oh you see that yellow marker was
it so we're waiting for the airdrop
heard a lot of gunshots going down over
here assuming people Oh
misdirection Wow like firecrackers
noisemakers what's up lu lu bow how you
doing where's it going down feel like
somebody's gotta be wounded down there
still fighting Aaron can't help himself
he's gonna go find out explore
investigate do you want to want to wait
for the air [ __ ] or do we wanna Armando
not that we know of I think the majority
of players are down there fighting
apparently let's see I mean I leave it
up to you you do what what your heart's
desire and I'll tell you when there's an
air drop question is actually where did
that gun fight just go down I didn't see
anyone so I just heard a lot of shooting
and I didn't see anybody think it was
over here though I mean I could hide in
a bush for ten minutes it's not very
captivating I want to know where the
wire is at all Seoul says I wouldn't be
surprised at Battle Royale no there is
later on I say you know maybe but I know
I kind of feel like I get like this
style of game this is I don't know are
you really gonna go for that shot and
give away your position yep you did it
well if you hit the shot we might as
well just call it extreme Oh hitmarkers
that was to hit markers pretty good
there and impressive feather how much
was the game cost I believe to play into
2018 as I mentioned it's like you have
to buy the airdrop founder's pack which
I don't know if I saw the price for that
but it'll be free in 2019 which is what
we have right now just so you guys know
they gave us a founder's pack to play
with so I have no idea how he's not that
he ran I saw him oh wait where's the
where's that airdrop I'm waiting for it
to come up on the map my marker so we're
just gonna wait here for a second for
the airdrop there it is oh it's close
all right we are in it so it is kind of
where the red circle is huh no that
guy's gonna have to come to me is it in
the red
just out of curiosity oh it holy is okay
but at least it's smart enough to be
like not in the water I don't know if I
want to run out in the open and get that
cuz that guy's wounded but he's yeah
he's here somewhere
so Sparky's giving us something fro here
it's like you have a safe sound your
filter which can be upgraded stuff you
go into areas up to eight people it's at
8 to 16 but in this case it's 8 I think
material scavenge to get back to your
shelter with it if you die you lose
everything but if you get to your
shelter it's all good it's a PvP only I
mean like you can technically avoid
people and just get loot and get stuff
and it's trying to bait the package I
think here to get that guy to come over
and grab it well somebody probably is
gonna just wrap around and grab it
oh there's one their seat they're going
for the package this is good so players
can't kill each other yes you can you
can loot them as well which is good
pretty sure he doesn't Hamza questions I
think I just saw me or not
up you're ready I did that so that's the
exit that you want by the way that that
dock is worthy he's down there oh he's
going for the package aaron mistakes
were made
okay you should just camp with the the
exit where's the exit
it's right there that's exit yeah he's
going for the package we're gonna kill
him as he grabs two just make sure you
don't get a screwed at the oh there's
another guy down
Road he's right there you see him yeah
questioned everyone's no no this is not
good I don't think we're gonna get the
package at this point if the package is
still read though perhaps I can't
you can't prone there there's no space
okay he's he's he's near the car he's
he's wrapping around I think he went up
the hill last I saw question is is he
gonna camp it
no but the exits farther or to your left
I don't even know where that guy went he
might be taking the the safe scenic
route near the water I'm gonna get
sandwiched if this guy's now they're
going for the package man is he moving I
don't know I didn't see the guy but I'm
guessing he went like water side you
know all right let's Jason all right
we're going for the big wraparound it's
probably will not go well but I'm gonna
hope well nobody's taking the package
yet which is kind of crazy it's still
red or the packages in a wonky ass spot
where you came and get it oh go down
that was a sniper I think never heard
that gun yet thanks Sparky for the info
uh what did I miss fruity loopy hello
okay okay okay I missed it fruity just
send it again I'm trying to watch the
game at the same time we'll be a free
game at launch Jennifer I don't think so
it sounds like you you need to buy the
finders pack for 2018 if you want to
play it in 2018 but I think in 2019
it'll become free the package is still
available this is not a battle royale
Geo all right so we're closing in on the
package but we feel like the package is
being baited because we definitely heard
a sniper shot there's also another guy
who just went this way so yeah you snuck
around
right now if you want to play it it's
part of the Xbox insiders program so
you'd have to feel like going under the
fact is a bad idea there's definitely
people camping the package I think so
gotta be yeah you're smarter than me I
would just don't close doors I don't
like people know where I've been all
right this is probably one of those like
as like more intense matches where
doesn't seem like anyone wants to grab
the package because everyone seems to be
camping it and probably getting out as
you saw last game it takes about eight
seconds I think to get out so you're not
technically safe just because you get to
that to the end point so it's definitely
it's getting camp from two sides because
just like Daisy I think there's like
certain elements of it because it's the
same devs Daisy ARMA does so yeah I
think that
so maybe the radiation is just a timer
to kind of get things moving along yeah
so that like you either have to make
that decision to go for it or just leave
the game organic sense all right we're
going back around the back
Oh Erin playing safe this is xbox only
Imperium as as of now at least can you
even do that oh you can oh you're just
really slow it's really slow do you
think there's an exit though on the
other side like something you can walk
past we're gonna find out nope there's
like a dock no that's the extraction
point
yeah normally you can these letters JK
the radiation is not a time where you
have to get out within a few minutes
okay so so I'm assuming if that ladder
didn't work this one's not gonna work
right and we should probably start I
think Thank You manager man we climb the
ladders did work in other places in the
game
okay well they're gonna have to grab it
and head back there soon so that's me up
our ladder game is not very strong cuz I
mean like part of the PvE is just
getting like materials and then getting
out but I mean I guess you could view
that as it could be empty
feel empty I need a headset show again
in the Astro 810 I don't know enough
about Astro is to tell you what kind of
had set to get so sorry about that
should we go for the clearly highly
camps box I don't know it's up to you if
you want to just give it a shot try to
grab the box and get the hell out don't
even engage with anyone go for it I mean
it's kind of boring just to extract of
course well I mean we don't know what
materials are in that package right that
was the whole point of trying to get the
package to begin with it was just trying
to see what kind of goodies you can get
from the from the package so I say we
make a break for the package try to get
the package at least see what's in the
package and even if we die at least
people know what's in the package is the
map huge I wouldn't say it's that big we
were able to kind of like go from one
side to the other in like a short amount
of time
Erin's still playing safe I'm actually
just trying to find my way there at this
point oh really okay I thought you were
like trying to find a safe route to get
there unless it's stuck on the building
which would be hilarious it could be on
the roof and that's why nobody has it
okay now we need to extract because
alright well I you're sick there's a
halfway decent chance that was on the
roof but we got to get out maybe that's
why nobody's got it yet yeah don't want
to get shot in the back by all the
people I just tried to flank okay so we
got nothing in that run we didn't kill
anyone
we didn't find anything this is pretty
much the worst kind of run that you
could have what the exits like right
there so we're fine kill someone please
we killed some people the last two games
and I got to hit markers earlier on some
guys but you know what are you gonna do
I can find people I'd be happy to kill
him that was weird I wonder if it the
airdrop was on the roof I don't know
okay well we'll try again that was a
weird one cuz all the other times the
airdrop has been in a field
well you can tell right away off the red
the red circle assuming it drops in the
red circle every time yeah we'll give it
one more go see if we can find it out in
the field and Master Nick you can play
it on xbox if you have the insider
program so yeah it's not battle royale
it's more like escape from tarkov or a
hunt showdown yeah except lunch our
daughters got some PvE though right
because you're killing stuff there's no
like stuff that you're killing yes one
that is also true
loading okay I'm just keep back up again
yeah let's just queue up what's the
objective of the game essentially you're
trying to you know extract as much
material as you can from each time that
you get into a game ideally probably the
airdrop so I have the best stuff then
you bring that back to your base if you
can live and then you upgrade your base
different things at your base for like
crafting and things like that we did see
maybe make better guns yeah grenades
grenades or something this is the
shooting range practice you can see as
soon as you start shooting you're
accessing crap can you hack this game
probably harder sitting on console but
hopefully not so right now we're
searching for three of eight players
oh we had five it's pretty accurate once
you get the actual crosshair on it with
certain weapons this gun not so much or
you don't actually have a fabulous Oh
so myself short maybe when you get to
like I'm gonna get to this range it the
name of this game is bigger
Eliz or I got it with this gun yeah so
the guns have different we got it I mean
you you once you gotta got your your aim
down on that last guy near the tree you
hit him twice and then he finally moved
so here we go alright hopefully the
airdrop will be somewhere obvious this
time I like how sneaky you can be yeah
yeah I mean degree for the comment about
killing people it's a risk I mean
because you lose all of your gear
every time you die it depends how much
gear you have collected but you wouldn't
want to run in every round and fight
other people in this game because you
could end up at a point where you only
have a knife yeah
if you lose all your gear every round so
it's not exactly PvP there isn't a
winner I mean not necessarily there's
just PvP elements to it I mean
ultimately you know if you do kill
somebody you can take their loot and
things like that but your main objective
is to try to get as much material out of
there but maybe killing someone would
have got you material because they might
have farmed some stuff so it's like hunt
showdown if you want a decent strategies
to just basically go camp and exit
loading is there bullet drop um I mean
we shot pretty far there and it didn't
look like there was too much bullet drop
but I don't know we haven't sniped at
all I noticed at really far ranges I had
aim high with okay the SMG how many guns
are there do you know mmm don't off top
my head back okay
I've seen a couple pistols couple rifles
in SMG as grumpier face man says you
don't need a PvP you can stealth and
then extract
yeah no that's back in that area again
it feels like I don't know this feels
like early plugged you where all the
battles were in one place alright I
don't really have I'm not gonna get
enough in this stream to actually craft
anything so let's just focus on that
airdrop their airdrop or fighting people
yeah so once you extracting ever lose it
no you don't but if you die you lose
whatever you have on you so you'll lose
the guns you lose the a most things like
that right now you can play it for free
Master Nick if you're in the insider
program but I think according to some
sites I think for once the game actually
comes out you might need founders pack
and then in 2019 it'll be free but don't
quote me on that because I'm not 100
percent sure that's just what I read is
there fishing nope sorry horse huh
there's not even fish on these racks
trying to see if there's any just random
cool areas so for rugs karaage
pretty says pretty much go play escape
from tarkov
I'm in sauna that's not a bad suggestion
you gonna play some tarkoff and just see
if this is your type of game it's this
scavenging survival yeah it's more
tarkov than it is a better rail so if
you guys are looking for a better route
that's not that's not what this is so
I'm on the peninsula already where it's
gonna go down I guess we got ammo damn
we need some wire it's so you can break
down stuff sci-fi there's a I guess this
is new map wise yeah this one just
appeared this morning I mean honestly
the the right thing to do would be to
just chill here because I'm actually
good well it could okay so I mean it's I
see where you're going with it it's good
I think so could be on the island that
I'm at or it could be across the way
someone mentioned its division battle
route yeah division battle royale was
called survival and it was quite
excellent
I really enjoyed that DLC and I mean the
dark zone
oh that okay I know what you're talking
about yeah the one where they actually
had a survival mechanic yeah their
survival DLC was great and I actually
kind of hope they bring that to Division
2 you mean that's a division to you I
want to see what they do to dark zone if
they're changing it at all but what
would you do to accent a I don't
actually like dark zone I think what
they did towards the end where they made
you know you going manhunt it actually
gave you like a reason a man like you
know actually pvp against people like
there was benefit like you got like more
reward I think out of it if you could
escape or if you could get your stuff
out as a manhunt or something like that
but as long as it's not glitchy
exploitative where you can like hide in
buildings and kill people I think it'll
be fine and as long as the PvE part of
it you can still you know still
progressing in a good fashion that like
doesn't force people to to dark zone or
PvP would be good as well like you know
what dark zone to be like that like the
best way to you know get gear and things
like that because not everyone's gonna
want a PvP right and the funny thing
about the first week of dark zone
probably will well maybe it's different
now that people have played it but like
usually people are friendly the first
week because everyone's just trying to
get stuff out
you never know right I'm interested to
see if that games gonna be better or
probably I'll be more into it come the
next time it comes around I didn't play
enough of the updated version which it
did a lot I think they did a lot to it a
lot of good things so as long as they're
building upon that stuff I think
divinity should be a pretty solid cue 1
2019 game but I'll definitely be getting
into I'm sure you will I know that
you're enjoying it play somebody 3 and I
really enjoyed it and it kind of still
scratches that H of the not destiny RPG
shooter I like it because they have like
that kind of deep crafting system trying
to find like perfect min max stats now
destiny way back in the day sort of had
that with some of the gun he's looking
at the map he's got he's got so much are
we trying to Luger you just roll up on
him he only has a pistol Aaron gets a
lot of yeah just full auto roll up on
him he's got no answer he probably ran
to be honest where'd you go soon the
farmhouse should I hit him off at the
other end of the farmhouse I just know
that that guy has a pistol and he stands
no chance depends if I really hurt right
now it's I've been bested by a knife a
big knife person yeah but I feel like he
was the knife has a better chance to
kill you than the than the pistol here
because you guys will both be having to
aim I think he found a way out unless
he's hiding where'd you get a Luger
mclarson OOP oh wait I just I thought I
felt through the floor but okay uh yeah
I think he got away guys
sadly surprise the airdrop hasn't
happened yet to be honest feels like
those first couple games it went pretty
fast that are we just now that we're
fixated on getting it what button is to
heal our right trigger
I think assuming you have the GAF to do
it you have to put away your stuff oh
that's the other interesting thing too
right yes
yeah do you have to make sure you don't
have a gun equipped or you can't heal
that's me says azim come back
oh airdrop okay
we got an ear job rod says to heel left
bumper to choose bandage right trigger
when he quipped yeah it works - you all
right where is that airdrop where's
Luger McClure Gerson cuz I don't know
azim ran
I think cuz he knew he only had a pistol
I don't want to get Lugard okay you
don't even know if it's a Luger it
could've been something else
where's HP though on the bottom right I
probably only shows up like when you
like ABS or take damage something that
where are you Luger man question is
where's the package
I just heard it yeah I heard a thunk
great he's on the roof oh that would be
so stupid no it's on the roof but Luger
mcglue Gerson could kill me while I'm
just grab it go where is it that's it
and then the the exit is like to your
left
I'll hurry up I heard gunfire just take
it run book it you know where it is
right it's uh that way yeah yeah are we
got the package but also everyone else
in the world knows or at least in this
game knows that we have the package
we're trying to get to the dock
we're beelining it wait where the hell
is the exit oh we ran the other way I
totally screwed you up I thought we were
closer blame day yeah I blamed hey
that's fine and I wanted to make it
spicy
there's no HP bar yet there is bottom
right you'll see it later once we get
shot here watch or do you think they're
camping it and we should have went the
long way should we get a long way
yeah let's go the long way I think going
along we might become extreme sniped by
Azim but whatever there you go check the
map oh yeah you guys aren't delay what's
up Peyman
alright we're weird we gave them the
Jukes we made him think we're going to
that closer exit but in reality we're
gonna go Oh Laurie
oh there's two I'll kill the guy that
has a gun the other guy has no gun use
them as bait why are you later than you
have 60 bullets habit
where does this guy yeah who cares about
the other guy the other guy's got no
good yeah but he's getting he might have
a nice
no I Aaron's in a sticky situation yes
let's just don't worry about his loot
unless the other guy picks up his gun
which would kind of be bad but whatever
we're not thinking that far ahead
I'm not running that fast you're
encumbered come on give me a better run
speed all right
so work the guy there's another guy that
was like I don't know
I think hiding from the other guy cuz he
had no gun or ran out of bullets this is
why you need a craft you can't come in
unprepared you're almost better off with
a knife in some cases to be honest think
I might have actually won with a knife
if that other guy with the other guy had
like three guns he had he had two like a
arse
a sim left okay well it's just game free
it's free right now for closed beta come
on
get there look at Aaron serpentining
trying to make sure that nobody sees him
as he escapes here whereas I would have
just ran straight
oh yeah okay now have you had the truck
or something or do you think they can be
back here can they be back here it's ten
seconds well they can't be back here
because they would have exited so yeah
that's good yeah we got it
BAM all right let's see what it is what
the fudge Eric why what did i do what
did I do wrong there we got the gun
oh okay so the crate oh hold wide a
weapon away it run faster oh yeah a
crate now I know what this is so this is
the crate that we got from the so we got
we got like an early access version they
gave us a crate like this you go
upstairs and you open it alright let's
go open a crate alright oh is the game
as laggy as it shows here yeah it
shouldn't be that laggy I mean it's hard
to sometimes when you watch something on
a stream it doesn't necessarily
correlate one-to-one so what's up chance
um you know that got my heart pounding
I'm not gonna lie well because he had
the box yeah but then I feel like we
actually could have killed both guys to
brown the other guy had nothing cuz he
was bait don't yeah sure gonna play
needs a lot of work it needs a little
bit of work uh
I don't know it seemed like Aaron
should've hit some of those shots that
he cross heard because he wasn't even
holding it down he's feathering them but
whatever we killed the other guy and we
got a crate so now we're gonna open a
crate possible contents ooh that's a lot
of material it said like you could get
it like a thousand aggressively useless
okay so we got a blueprint which is oh
wait you got okay but you already had
that blueprint for that gun did we yeah
it's the the gun you always use no man
we got like oh you ol and chemicals I
don't know you don't even need chemicals
right now right you need um electronic
parts so we need wire you know and have
wire nails all right we're gonna do one
more match let me let me let me try
something real quick so I think you can
go to any menu from here so there's a
there's a menu with like your stuff
although I might have to be downstairs
for it and the resources on the right
when you're back on that other menu so
go back is it resources are there gift
resources okay so I was trying to figure
this part out it looks like you can
convert it you convert it to what nails
okay but it looks like everything
converts to nails and plants so you need
nails because you don't have enough
nails but I need wire which is the more
important one I mean like a lot you
break down some chemical we'll see what
that does shouldn't electronics turn in
like electronics should turn into it's
just turning into those points that you
have up there which I guess you need to
spend on break this down so chemicals or
so you have four thousand out of four
thousand I don't know what that does
also it seems like you should have had
more than four thousand but whatever so
materials full but we just don't have
enough nails and wire I don't know we
haven't quite figured out the economy
yet Oh repair shelter and level up we
can do that now alright do that okay the
next upgrade is at six thousand fifty
minutes but we so can we just sell our
material so maybe you don't need to
right so like let's say we can't craft
this on stream because we definitely
don't know where to get it but we can
just so we know that you have to find it
on the
thing so that's worth 100 500 a thousand
so what if we just let's try it don't
burn the wire yeah not the wipe they
don't burn the wire the nails okay so
I'm out to deconstruct how many do we
have of these why does it say we have
infinite we have more than ten
apparently folks Oh are we breaking the
game just keep going all right break oh
you can't oh it's not letting me do it
okay that's hilarious actually
so like metal parts oh I see we can we
can deconstruct more than we have okay
so let's just you can track 44 of these
the only getting 220 whatever it's a rib
this one's worth a lot 41 that's all we
needed right we know you need 6,000 for
this next upgrade so you need 1,900 more
we got this 26 you're gonna blow
everything all right
short no it doesn't go over no we got
six thousand no no I know but the game
isn't smart enough to give you more
yeah like dependent so if you guys break
down stuff make sure you do it exact or
as exact as you can because you're
shafted you're gonna get you have to
really access so so we still didn't get
any wire out of that or nails but we
have six thousand six thousand so it
says Oh since you say okay so your
shelter is not level three so you can't
make it oh the next upgrade right yeah
not until I guess we probably have to
build some of this do I get to that yeah
first okay let me key up for a match
actually let me dump my sorry grumpier
we are a little bit confused because we
haven't played it that much
we just we kind of learning as we go uh
nevermind Eric that was the last time I
tried to help you I told you not to
shoot and you hope the other guy kill me
I didn't know that was you first of all
and second of all we tried to save you
cuz he shot Erin shot at the guy that
was shooting you and we never shot you
so we did finish I don't know what to I
don't know what to say there why don't
you get in one more and then see this
map call it a day we'll see if we can
find that when you upgrade your base
your material limit goes up
okay you need to buy the level to
upgrade before you can repair in level
up yeah I mean we don't have the
material we don't have the wire or the
Nate the three other nails that we need
is there any visible difference no looks
the same okay
I mean it seems like the yes michael
betting field if you have Xbox insider
you can download this for free right now
the beta bigger beta
Simo to the south side of your shelter
your what pile is full surprise the
backside of it get a wood pile is it
that
yeah you do have dang thanks rod
ah I've got 320 wood okay so we're wood
electronics B in our base I think it's
gonna be in the garden yeah we grow
nails here yeah I don't know there's
usually nails in every garden I've ever
been in just saying thanks rod there's
anything else we're forgetting police
tell us thank you so are there other
resource areas again sure as you build
out your base that's the stuff that
you're getting probably totally right so
like state of decay a little bit teeny
bit so go back to that second upgrade
will decrease the time of weapon
crafting about 1%
I have no generate 10 materials per hour
I've not crafted a weapon oh that's like
wood ok so what's the name of this game
ask hungry poor vigor is the name of
game I mean it's gonna be important that
you can craft weapons because you lose
your weapons when you die so if you
don't wanna be knifing McKnight person
or like Luger McGee from the last round
rod says plant tacks grow nails if only
it worked that way one day all right
where this is gonna be our last match
hopefully get an airdrop out of there
see what we get from a crate maybe if we
get lucky and we get enough material
somehow we can do it but I think since
we're like 9 wire off I don't see it
happening but I've yet to find any wire
I don't actually know where the wire is
oh wait I didn't see actually I saw you
get nails not wire you of course to be
fair we've been focusing there big bad
wolf women focusing on resources the
wood pile is the first upgrade you
bought ah I got you thank you yeah cool
thank you to the chat we just open a
copy of this yesterday and played a
couple hours a digital copy yeah digital
copy there's a good time if you guys
haven't subscribed you guys should so
you guys can find out when we go live
and or when we put up cool features
reviews previews gameplay all that stuff
another potato mode will be out in two
days
if you have much potato mojo II take
some of the most beautiful looking games
and turns them into mush
also you got grape hoppers the second
episode tomorrow with Mike and Rob if
you guys haven't heard a game grave
hoppers excuse me it is a new livestream
every Thursday at 2 p.m. Pacific where
Mike and Rob will go through a list of
games and within that list of games
they're gonna play it at a1 say the
hardest difficulty but a harder
difficulty and see how long they can
survive in that game if they make it
through the episode then they'll
continue on to the next episode but
let's take for example the first episode
if you guys watched it it was far cry 5
and I won't spoil too much but you can
go watch to see if Rob survived his far
cry 5 experience if he didn't obviously
there's a new game tomorrow so tune in
tomorrow for that one as well but we're
playing bigger beta now on Xbox one
we're playing on a 1x and it's available
for Xbox insiders we were able to
finally extract a air drop last game
we're gonna try to find another drop
here and or you know find some materials
which is what part of the game is
looking for resources to bring back to
your base the airdrop obviously gives
you that crate which has more stuff in
it blueprints this is like a place that
you'd find like why you're at right
there you go 6 wire yeah alright so what
do we need 3 more wires so we just need
to find another building with like a
toolbox I mean honestly what you want to
run yeah like guys reloaded game I don't
wanna do you haven't died yet Aaron it
wouldn't make it fun you haven't died
yet so we're not gonna do it but we
found a [ __ ] so if we die we're losing
this wire but it's uh we know what it is
get to the next set of buildings we'll
just keep looking for stuff right it's
like there yeah on the way I know
there's stuff underneath that too like
right there but we'll see so we know the
shed had some wire so this is like dayz
a little bit it's made by the same
developer looking interactive so found
some stuff which is good stuff we need
for the next upgrade so it actually as
Erin mentioned would suck if we lost it
but I'm going to force
to play it through because it'll add
spiciness to this stream if I was
playing on my own I would just get out
right now and do I know you would but 2
loading screens can you teen them up no
well now that we know I mean other than
like someone joining our game and
helping us like crime did last game were
those two guys fighting each other no so
crime the guy with no gun was crime from
from the stream and he said he was
acting as bait for us as the other guy
shot him so we just didn't shoot the
other guy in time to save crime your
effort was valiant and we salute you
where are you going
by the way towards the marker we were
looking for more sheds ok well hopefully
they'll all fight over the air drop
which is yeah kind of in the direction
we're going
so I don't think it was like a shed in
particular that had it yeah there's a
lot of goodness basically you're just
looking for toolboxes right or like it
was kind of I don't want to jinx it but
this is where we got stabbed the first
time oh anything in the hut at the
beginning of the stream I don't want to
end the stream the same way how we isn't
this where we killed like two guys to
you though yeah this is a big fight and
zone I think it's because it's one of
the only challenge I mean this game is
on xbox though so that's one difference
already and I would say this looks you
know better visually and graphically
then you know some of their previous
games they know how you look at it at
least compared to like Daisy but I think
it's this is one for the come on yeah
that wire yeah sure we just get out and
try it do you have enough nails how many
nails was it you have fine you can get
out and upgrade I guess now that we
actually have enough just find an exit
alright the exits over here no he did
vault that time letting him off the hook
good job all thing this is not a battle
royale alpha all right let's run back
real quick this is what the division
should have been huh I don't like that
but I mean their survival DLC was fun
enough so if you wanted something like
that go do that here's where I will
concede some of that point is a division
could have more survival elements to it
which the survival DLC is say pointed
out kind of brought into it but also
division i don't okay you and i probably
disagree on this a little bit but feel
like it could have been a little bit
less of an RPG like i would have
appreciated if the dark zone had just
been a gun is a gun and there weren't
two you know with stats balance like
destiny how destiny stats all my stuff
because all your gear would not matter
either then too and part of the the
reason the division has like a nice
little twist is that you can't have like
what armor sets and things like that
that you're actually trying to achieve
or get to so like not having that after
spending like how many you know hours or
whatever playing the game is kind
like weird to me because I mean even
though your level balanced in destiny
for example right your guns still do
what your guns are supposed to do and
your exotic armors do what they're
supposed to do - but it's I see what
you're saying and I think they probably
still could have retained some of that
in PvP like was it Firebird where
certain number of rounds just catch
people on fire I don't know like when
you line up so it when you have stats
the way you do in division
you can't give a drop on people like you
can have a sniper rifle and post up in
the perfect spot land the perfect
headshot and if the guy is just way
higher level than you it just doesn't do
anything yeah but that's how the game
works though right so I mean like yes
you know in a you know situation where
like normally a sniper shot would kill
you in one shot then sure but you know
they've clearly said oh we're short no
we're good no so we did the wood pile
wood log level one so we're short for
crafting table but we could do scrap in
so what scrap in do you generate
something metal i generate spur our
metal parts each hour sure so if you do
that shouldn't you be level three at
that point if I do this yeah because
that's the third tier right so it says
shelter level so you'd be level three
and then you have enough technically
materials to it's not letting me do it
which means I think we needed fifty wire
to do level two or I can just oh you
know it might be built that was not high
enough all right so if you do that
you'll get to build level two of
fourteen and the level three requires
you to be build level six so okay now
you should just pretty much head back
into a back into a game because it
doesn't sound like unless we have to
wait for the build in progress so it'll
generate ten materials per hour now
collect it regularly it's placed next to
the shelter on the south side okay so
that's the wood pile that's the wood
pile so now the wood pile will generate
more stuff okay
make sense all right well hop back into
one last round yes this is the last
round
because today was nice enough to let me
extract and figure out how the crafting
works in this game 10 70s are expensive
shared dropped in place but stayed high
because the crypto miners actually funny
thing is like yesterday for like a very
brief window of time the 1070 TI I think
was like mispriced
on Amazon and somehow you got that deal
good for you because it was less than
$400 I think I would have bought it if I
had known about it sooner I always hate
out games I get the most hype evolved
division destiny Assassin's Creed unity
they all come out shitty I don't know I
thought destiny eventually got a lot
better I enjoyed it I still play it to
some degree but yeah I will say evolve
I appreciate games that try something
new even if it doesn't necessarily work
it was kind of like 10 minutes of
chasing a monsters but which wasn't
exactly compelling I had fun playing as
a monster yeah I think like I never
liked playing evolve as one of the
hunters cuz I just thought it was a pain
in the ass to follow the monster but as
the monster I was like oh cool I know
exactly what I'm trying to do here right
I I am trying to level up as fast as I
can while avoiding hunters because I
don't want to fight them at level one
and I can't wait because I want to level
up and evolve into the my next tier
monster either 2 or 3 so that I can
wreck the crap out of the hunters like
that that was fun to me but I never
enjoyed being the hunter always trying
to chase them down and I know there's
strats too like you know you like you
snare them and you know try to like slow
him down we you kill stuff so that he
can't have upgrades and things like that
but like for me it was always more fun
to play as the monster same with like a
game like dead by daylight right like I
always had more fun playing the killer
than I did playing the people that like
the survivor is trying to like escape
cuz I don't know maybe I'm a person that
wants to kill people I guess you know
here's what I would have done with
evolved I think there should have been
more fights in any given round so I
would have given the monster a life per
level so that the monster would come
around and fight you at least one time
per per level that they were gaining hmm
so like you would have is more fair or
something yes you would have like maybe
for smaller monster fights per round as
opposed to like just chasing them all
the map then getting into one epic fight
at the end Maddie you need to be any
Xbox insider so make sure you have the
Xbox insider app first on the Xbox store
destiny is the worst game there ever was
says Raj Raj I don't know I still think
it's got some of the best shooting
mechanics and like like gun sounds and
things like that
I agree with you don't you dope who said
the raids in d2 are poop compared to d1
raids well some d1 raids were not that
good and DTS raid the main rate is
better than some of the d1 raids for
sure as to gamer says yep you must be an
insider I will say that between d1 and
d2 I had children and a psychopath yeah
okay d2 is so much better for like dads
and people who can't put a ton of time
into it for casual players it is oh
there's a person right in front we saw
him he's down at that that tree line
that second set of trees yeah him should
take a long jet mmm I would not but it's
up to you yeah I think just to kind of
piggyback on what you said I think that
they went too much that way they swung
too far to the casual side and I hope
that come forsaken that there's some
balance because even now in the in the
later part of destiny two's a life cycle
or whatever and and all the updates and
things like that they've definitely gone
more back to the hardcore route or at
least some of it is and maybe some of
that's just because it's more grindy but
there definitely can be a balance I mean
while learned a lot they kind of went
too casual at one point and I think they
finally found a good balance somewhere
in between now somewhere something that
the hard cores will still like to play
but the casuals can still get into it I
hate to use the word casual play okay
like someone that doesn't know many
hours a day into a game you know they're
probably playing like an hour too if
that a day you know it's not I would not
take that as a desert insult in any way
shape or form I just think like a lot of
us as we get older just have less time I
can see that and so knowing how much
time I have to put in what I'm
to get out of it like the weekly
milestones are perfect this is not a
battle royale tricks man that guy was
running this direction and now are you
looting my guess look for some open
doors let's be smart about it a little
paranoid that they saw me and they just
took a prone is this better graphics
than pokey for xbox I mean yes but I
mean only from the standpoint of there's
like less people on the map and the map
isn't as big not nearly as big so from
that standpoint yeah nope there is got
him he's got no gun I can already tell
you that he's got no gun which way to go
left or right he went back into the
house I think which would be really
stupid maybe he ran maybe you're right
maybe he like ran ran down the cliff
what have you just did that every game
just didn't bring a gun with you and
you're just looting to try to run out
there's a point where you might have to
do that oh how they need you q and he's
out of there
chazzy AGS long time no see yeah what's
up man it's a good opportunity for him
to stab me um okay so I agree with you
on one thing then that's I agree the
unplanned things but like a destiny to
could have treated hardcore players
better like we're there now I feel like
there they were they were so afraid of
giving you things that I couldn't earn
because I didn't have the time to earn
it and I think that's a mistake like you
you could have had the flaming fist of
awesome or whatever that from the raid
and I'd respect that because I just
don't have time to raid that's cool you
know you don't have to give me
everything as a casual player our
enemies real players yes that we know is
it an open beta it's only for insiders
so I don't know if that's technically
open beta but because I personally
haven't had to try to like get onto Xbox
insiders but it seems like downloading
Xbox insiders is not very hard
so yeah Neil's good eight nails is very
good
he went into the house so I was rights
Nonna it doesn't matter did he go back
in that no no no this is we're on delay
so there's no way like now open the door
he left too it's too late
yeah it's too late sorry we got delay
obviously so a rag get some some sweet
meds I didn't see what's direction here
in close-quarters fights are a bit janky
in this game it's kind of hard to that's
where I would store ammo you seen your
table your nightstand I kind of want to
open a window and get somebody out of
window just because you can do it in
this game I haven't seen a window yet
seems like these bags feel like they
should have stuff out it's early access
so maybe yeah I mean oh that thing's
yeah I just feel like they're not gonna
make it's so easy to get stuff right
although I guess there would be more
incentive if you were able to just find
things easier but then I you would
escape faster so I don't know tension
that that truck was searchable by the
way question is did that guy go there is
80s Stefan yeah that's the only time you
get first-person like this in the 80s
I'm a little bit worried about the
capability to dolphin dive to which
people haven't really fully figured out
yet but metal parts so you can daisy yes
yes manny although i can't since you're
not listening the audio i guess i didn't
come through shotguns are real good at
close-range actually you gotta watch out
do you have shotgun and not on me right
now but i'd definitely raft one one shot
at a dude I actually felt air jabs
coming in
is messaging me on the slack as well get
an airdrop and pay to see how it goes
all right we'll go up to airdrop and
then we'll go ahead and hand the screen
there see if we get another crate or die
trying
oh we got so I'm 31
yep oh I saw the airdrop there it is it
actually fell oh nice it's got a little
parrot is that a parachute or is that a
rock no it's got a parachute oh okay
once it got caught in a tree I'm gonna
say it got cotton tree it's early access
data it's only beta if we can grab that
airdrop we can just go straight down the
mountain here all right let's do it
assuming we don't get hella jacked uh
what do you think is no man sky now yes
man sky ah from the little that I've
heard in the office of the people
playing the current update there they're
definitely enthusiastic about next week
we're gonna be playing no mess guy next
week for sure on Tuesday we might even
do like a little pre pre update type
like stream on one day I know Rob Jake
are pretty deep into it and then um Mike
starting on PC and then Peter swapping
from ps4 to PC too so curious to see you
know what the multiplayer looks like
that they kind of teased with the
trailer yesterday but yeah we'll
definitely be getting into some no man's
sky next week guys so if you guys are
interested in that or curious about that
check it out and know once guys gonna be
out for Xbox for those that haven't
played it yet and are looking for a game
to play it could be a lot better just
because of all the updates and some of
the stuff coming from the next update
next all caps next so for to get this
game you need the Xbox insider which you
need to get from the store and then
what's your next box inside our search
for that way but if you're not an
insider you won't be able to get this
game for free we are do you know if you
run faster without a gun in your hand I
don't one was saying you do but I don't
know if that's fact or not but I think
it's safer to have you go now maybe I
don't want to run with a gap again in my
hand
oh you're afraid I am I got the thing
and everybody knows where I am it's it's
a beta for those that are Xbox insiders
solar so sort of sort of not open
alright we're trying to get out
hopefully this box has better stuff for
us we have ran into no opposition no
jinx me now you ran into no opposition
no one's even following you easy life
easy stream it landed would it rather
have had somebody yeah what plans on war
warframe stuff I'm oh faces you know I
always kind of wanted to get into
warframe I just knew that it would be a
huge time sink if I did because at that
time I was playing a lot of destiny but
everyone was saying if you play destiny
you should play warframe and anyways I
just don't have that time anymore to go
Yolo and over again start to start from
scratch and I heard like warframe when
you're first starting out you almost
want to try to like you hope to have
like somebody that's knowledgeable about
the game because there's a lot of
systems in that game yeah and and it's
easier if someone's there to kind of
like guide you along a little bit Bob
Jones saying I'm gonna get warframe on
switch yeah that could be it the thing
that helps you know propel more players
is let's see what we get from crate it's
buzzing
it's controller name I agree there but
quite a lot a thousand material a
thousand fifty materials in a 74 k sure
cool oh you know what sucks what's that
we were kept and you don't get any more
materials on top of your 6000 so silly I
mean this silly that you can't go over
your max but alright cuz like what else
are you gonna spend it on so you could
craft could you have crafted like a
weapon or something would that have
taken up the parts let's so the crafting
bench is downstairs but I haven't like I
know here we'll take a quick look before
we end there's a there's a crafting
bench down here and it seems like a
place where I should be able to do this
so improve customized resources
character just came again there was
somewhere in here before where you could
actually screw with individual weapons
somehow but I don't see a weapon
crafting thing well okay here we go
craft okay now I got it so so if I want
to craft an aka so we have the
blueprints now so I can't craft these
okay cool
so what does this cost me there you go
okay so yeah so okay so you want to
spend your okay never go out with full
materials because you're gonna come back
in craft
yeah you got a craft first but it's it's
weird cuz it and I see if you want to
deconstruct parts of the webbing right
well because you have one to deconstruct
right so so you can repaint which is not
there yet you can craft which is not an
option yet why not some reason would let
me craft it but didn't I just get that
blueprint and I just hold crap oh crap
today it's it's a blanked out right now
maybe you have too many idle it could be
that it's not the one that I got so
let's try craft you craft a weapon you
need to find the weapon you want to
craft like six times and dismantle it
and you need points so you have to find
it
thanks Luke okay so I have why don't you
want to break one of those down yeah
once you deconstruct that bad boy okay
so say pshh yep here we go there you go
do you want to deconstruct this weapon
to get apart sure yes
random part what do we get it didn't say
let's just do it we're doing all of it
alright we're doing another random part
okay so you can see here on the left
it's starting to give us so we have
these parts oh that you can then be
construct as well okay you can actually
if you construct that one now sure
alright so you know so we have too much
money now and Anacapa ah we gotta make a
gun first make go make a gun before we
teach anything else you say we can't
craft that one what did we pick up we
definitely got that one the suit the
summe whatever I know for sure we got
that blueprint craft there you go
it only cost 800 and you only take it's
less than a minute to make okay and that
takes the resources there mob they're
out there yet no now we can deconstruct
actually you probably want to make more
stuff but whatever you only let me make
one so now I can also apparently make
ammo its although it's not really lame
okay here we go wait no so right trigger
there you go ammo craft okay so now I
consumables so we can craft Parabellum
oh you can't craft any of that can craft
this check it out okay
grenade we can craft it no again okay so
we have to break gather parts so we're
still in the gathering parts phase okay
this is making a lot more sense now so
you have to gather the resources in the
world you have to break it down to make
the blueprint and then you can craft it
from this menu alright that seems like
why we're gonna get a knife bunch of
like knife you make nine persons on this
yeah you got a knife it out alright and
what a stream that was bigger beta for
those on the Xbox insider get on that if
you want to try it out air and last
thoughts before we get out of here on
vigor or maybe maybe first thoughts I
guess since you've only really played
for a couple hours now yeah I mean first
thoughts are it's a survival game it's
not even necessarily a game where you
have to fight other people
you get materials you break them down at
your base you upgrade your base and you
decide whether you want to fight or not
depending on how much risk you want to
take or you'll end up with a knife you'd
be the only man with a knife
some people can name though that night
that knife is actually pretty deadly
yeah so that's kind of just a quick look
at that I'm sure as it kind of
progresses as the game bigger progresses
we'll probably maybe check it out again
this is a new map if for those that
we're playing it earlier this week I
think it was like a wintery map blast
last time yeah it was interesting kind
of like here we're not here but on that
map was it Fisk factory yeah here's the
map real quick so then the two maps yes
sir I gotta go back then so the two maps
yesterday were dragged forward and then
there was like a snowy map in the upper
right corner so I'm guessing it rotates
around okay Norway cool but yeah thanks
everyone for tuning in we'll see you
guys back tomorrow at 11:00 for GameSpot
daily 11:30 for GameSpot live and then -
for gray poppers so we got three live
streams tomorrow come back hang out with
us appreciate it if you haven't served
you guys should sub for multitude of
reasons just to get informed when we go
live all the cool features we do all the
cool reviews previews things like that
thanks Erin for playing Thank You Tay
and we'll see you guys next time see you
have a good one